what are you doing / I like it so I have  a lot of that and mm sweet laughs great  I'm a personal shopper there's very high  profile thank you  she can't do normal things so I decided  to do is nothing better to do besides to  Sakura waiting what are you waiting for  [Music]  my twin brother died here - I said we  made this out  whoever died first was on the other side  from the afterlife  zombies  [Music]  you hear  I had a sign you sure there were the  present you think Lewis is here I don't  know Kiera I'm just gonna drop these bag  for you guys Hey  [Music]  Kerr was murdered  what were you doing at her buried why  are you asking our law I can't tell  whether or not going crazy  but for you can kiss me  you